let's say that the settlement price for
delivering 1000 pounds of apples on
October 20th which we're going to assume
is one year from now let's assume that
it's $200 let's also assume that the
current market price for a thousand
pounds of apples is also $200 so that
future settlement price is the same as
the current market price and we're also
going to assume like the last example
that these apples that we have never go
bad they're just things that they'd
never rot or anything so there's good in
a year as they are right now let's also
assume above and beyond the assumptions
of the last video that we can borrow and
sell apples in the current market that
we can actually short apples and when I
borrow so I go to someone who's got a
thousand pounds of apples who doesn't
really see any need for them over the
next year and say can I borrow those
apples and what I do is I say I'll
borrow those apples I'll sell those
apples in the market today and of the
interest that I get on those apples I'm
going to give you 1% the person who
actually owns the apples and that person
says oh sure why not that way I actually
get some money on my apples that I had
no intention of using for a year and
then I as the borrower and seller will
get 4% net
I'll get 4% net on the apples so given
this reality what could I do once again
to make a risk-free profit well as you
can imagine I can borrow and sell the
apples for a year so let me write this
down I'm going to borrow and sell 1,000
pounds of apples 1,000 pounds of apples
so if I just borrow it today and sell it
today's market price is $200 for a
thousand pounds so I'm going to get I'm
going to get 200 I'm going to get $200
now on top of that what I want to do is
agree to be the buyer I want to be
agreed to be the buyer on this futures
contract so let me write that down
agree agree you could say to go long the
futures contract or agree to be buyer to
be buyer on futures contract on the
futures contract so I'm agreeing a year
from
now to buy a thousand pounds of apples
for $200 so let's fast forward let's
fast forward one year so what's happened
so of the two hundred dollars I got from
shorting the apples I got five percent
on that but had to give one percent to
the person I borrowed the apples from so
I'm getting four percent net four
percent on two hundred dollars is to is
eight dollars so now I now have I now
have two hundred and eight dollars
because I got that four percent interest
it was two hundred and ten I gave two
dollars to the person who lent me the
apples now I can use two hundred dollars
of that to essentially uphold my part of
the futures contract to buy the apples
for $200 for that agreed-upon price so
$200 $200 to buy apples buy apples and I
know I can do this regardless of what
the market price is because that was
that was the delivery price on the
futures contract so now I have eight
dollars net now I have eight dollars net
and those apples that I've just bought
those thousand pounds of apples I can
then use those apples to return it to
the person that I borrowed the apples
from so they got their apples back and
they got that one percent on the two
hundred dollars over the course of the
year and I made a risk free eight
dollars so if you think about it once
again this is kind of setting a lower
bound on what the actual settlement
price on the futures contract is I
should not be able to make this
risk-free profit if it's available then
people will do it and what it will do is
it will increase demand to be the buyer
here so this price should go up and it
would increase supply on the selling
side here and so maybe this price over
here would go down